hi everyone it's jerry let's have a look
at a game from round one of the 44th
chess olympiad
on the white end
india's vidiq gujarati playing on team
one of india
board one
they have three teams in this event
his opponent from zimbabwe international
master rodwell makoto
opening wise we have a king's indian
defense i think if you're a fan of this
opening you'll enjoy this one especially
if you
play
the bayonet attack or maybe find
yourself trying to defend against it i
think there are a lot of useful tips in
this one game
so
b4 on this move 9 is what denotes the
bayonet attack
what are we looking to do is white we're
looking to break with c5 we're looking
to play
on the side of the board where we have
space
how does black interfere with this
a5
there are only two good follow-ups for
white one is bishop a3 keeping the
tension
still in a spot
to play c5
or the move plate in the game
b takes a
if is white you're reacting to a5 with
a5 with b5
it's this opening this attack is
being misplayed because after b6 this
shuts down the queen side there will be
no good pawn breaks
and this buys black all day to make
progress on the king's wing
f5 f4
this is probably not going to end so
well for team white
all right
b takes a in the game
rook takes a
a4
this is an important pawn to invite into
the mix
uh
if at some point black wants to clamp
down on c5 make this break harder to get
in well white is now only going to be a
step away from engaging with that b6
pawn
creating more tension
creating more open lines
all right from here it's 97 this knight
will be really strong on c5 black is
also clearing the way for the king's
indian defense break
f5
so this guy needs to be challenged in
order for white to make progress in this
game
the king knight has that responsibility
they are exchanged and surprisingly
enough
as early as this move 14 the most
natural move
in this position for black
f5
that's a blunder
white is now winning
not so clear why that is the case though
i'll throw it to you as a pop quiz
uh
white to move what is best here feel
free to pause the video
okay here we go the best move is c5
why though
let me first note
c5 was not played in the game
this was vidit's biggest think of the
game he spent about 22 minutes on this
move 15.
he ends up playing f3 in this position
reinforcing e4
being in a spot to meet pawn takes with
pawn takes
and by maintaining a pawn here white is
maintaining control over black's worst
positioned piece the knight on e7
let's see why c5 is so good
there are a couple captures but before i
touch on the captures on
c5 let's look at a line where black says
i'm all right with allowing this pawn
break i don't want to bite
i'm just going to allow you to take on
d6 this is really really bad for black
notice these nice developing moves
bishop to e3 nice forward move
generating a threat
white's moving forward black is running
in reverse
black is making awkward moves
obstructing the bishop if you go here
there's knight to b5 there's a problem
there
white is getting all these open lines
for free
no no material investment d6 can be hit
the rook hit enter on the seventh rank
this is really really bad approaching a
plus three
advantage for white
the big question here what happens on
the captures well first this is the
simple one to cover
you take with the pawn there's now d6
that's gonna hurt that's a check this is
the downside with f5 the king is exposed
the queen's already on that diagonal
the knight's going to fall the big
question
what's happening if rook takes c5 not so
clear
not the most
natural follow-up
the best move in this position is now a5
what's that doing it's robbing the rook
of a safe square
c5 is now the only
safe square for the rook and nearby
there is bishop e3 winning the exchange
how does black stop that
one might think f4
but there's another path to track down
the rook
not knight a4 because there's rook takes
pawn
we first make this one baby move
one step bishop d2 and now next up
there's knight a4 this will be defended
directly and the rook is a goner
if you want to save the rook with b6
well hang on how valuable is this pawn
computer likes this position a real lot
for white plus five
okay anyhow c5 is there
tactically
in the game it's f3
next up king h8
uh another move that you may want to
keep in mind as black here
king h8 is one of the top moves but
another one to
maybe consider playing on the black side
is c5
what is what is one way to interpret c5
what is that move maybe saying here c5
is saying aha
the queen side is now closed what are
you going to do about it you want to
open up
the queen side
by taking on poisson
well if you do that you're now
inviting my second ranked knight
into the center square d4
the weakest square in your camp and
you're gonna have to work around that
night
this is
uh something to consider is black it's
another path forward
in this game it's king h8
my first thought with king h8 is okay
you're you're getting off the diagonal
in fact that was really my only thought
but in preparing for this video and
looking at some different lines i
realized
oh you know what there's an additional
point so like to highlight what that is
it is opening up the g8 square for the
knight in some cases
why is the knight may be useful on g8
well
if
if this pawn is always going to be
maintained yeah we're going to try to
reposition the knight to maybe f6
h5 f4 or
note that the knight on g8 is also
allowing black to maybe
consider
this strategic idea to exchange dark
square bishops
now this is a
a decision that black must weigh very
carefully
especially with the queen still on board
if we exchange dark square bishops the
king can be the black king could be a
bit more vulnerable
but what i can say is if the queens are
off
i think this is almost
always going to be a desirable exchange
for black to get the dark square bishops
off
something to keep in mind it is not only
not only about getting off the diagonal
but this nice pivot on g8 is available
with bishop h6 as an idea all right
from here we have bishop a3
this rook needs to be given a shove
so that white could get in that c5 move
from here
uh black now plays c5 so one move later
uh an additional move here's a mistake i
ended up making myself
uh i think this is a
ju just like
f5 was a mistake a very natural move but
it turns out uh it's it's flawed
here's uh here's a mistake i ended up
making and preparing for this video
after
if instead of c5 if b6 is in there
uh bishop b4 is a good follow-up and
what do you think the next move is here
for white
i'll just share it with you the move i
thought
was the automatic follow-up
a5 that's not working
it looks really natural
right we made all these moves here
we got the bishop on a3
the bishop on b4
we want to get the break in a5 so that
we could get in c5 it's not there
because black has this c5 move again
this is this c5 move is showing up
uh
against the bayonet attack
what's the problem now well if you back
up you're dropping the pawn and if
you're capturing on c6 hang on this pawn
is now hit for a third time what are you
gonna do about it team white how do you
save the pawn
this is also an option maybe this is
still an option
and if you're capturing here you're
losing
white is losing
because
look at we could have the queen do
similar take advantage of this
this king that's on the open diagonal
right we have
a couple variations i'm highlighting
here where
each side's queen could be a great pest
to the king
the bishop is going to fall next
anyhow
my point here is that
if b6 is played in this position after b
bishop b4 and rook to a8 it's important
not to play a5 this is still a fine
position for white
instead of a5 best would be knight b5
first what is that doing well
it's preventing c5 if you play c5 now
there's a problem
on d6
so only after
knight is on b5 and the bishop is here
only then could white next
look to play this a5 advance
these are important
uh structural
details
uh to note
okay in this game it is c5
white wants the position to open up so d
takes c
knight takes c
and from here we have bishop to d3 we
have a
with this last move well the bishop on
dt on on e2 excuse me what was it even
doing
uh it has a role now it's
watching over e4
there's a
a changing of the guard that is
happening here
now that the
bishop is securing e4
this knight is free to go elsewhere it
wants to go to b5
next up we have bishop h6
uh there isn't
there isn't really a good way to prevent
this bishop from taking up this active
post on the a7 to g1 diagonal
in the game vid it puts his king in the
corner he says if you're going to get
there you're not getting there with
check
it's a move i'm going to have to make
anyway so let me just make it right now
if you try to
stop bishop to e3 that's
it's not going to work
if rook to e1
there's
there's bishop to d2
and if you play here still watching out
for this that's going to hurt
knight d4
black would be winning so if black
really wants to get into e3 he's going
to get in there so
king king to h1 in this position
bishop e3
knight b4
and bishop to c5 so there was two on
this this was the best move defending
against d6
and from here
we have rook a to d1 the computer isn't
a great fan of this move
uh there is
another continuation and we're once more
what i'm about to highlight is once more
related to a different structure that
can surface
instead of rook a to d1 the computer is
suggesting
break open this position
it says go ahead and take on f5 first
and then immediately challenge this pawn
duo with f4
now
if
you're playing as white here and you're
not coming up with this
sequence the capture on f5 and then the
follow-up f4
what could maybe
what are some cues
what are some
some things to look into that could
maybe help you find these moves
notice what happened on these last few
moves
what what did black do
black
relocated this bishop
went to h6
e3 in c5 what has happened
it's no longer
a defender for the king
it's a defender of the d6 pawn
but it is primarily now
functioning
as an aggressive piece
no longer a good defender for the king
so this may prompt white to crack open
the center
one less defender now for the king and
when we when we consider the structures
black has one pawn white has two
white is
white has the safer king there are no
uh
main diagonal checks that can hurt white
but there certainly are
some main diagonal checks that can hurt
black and i'd like to highlight one of
them right now
a knee-jerk reaction to f4 in this
position would be to play
a knee-jerk reaction to this
f4 move would be to play e4 this would
be losing for black i'd like to just put
on this variation to show why there's a
check
we could already have some sacrifice
this is a really neat line
uh what is this capture doing it is
paving the way it's a clearance
sacrifice for queen g3
and i'm just going to bring it to a
point where we win a queen
how's this knight c7 and you have to
give up
the queen right now
anyhow
if you want to
uh
convert your
mainly defensive piece into an
offensive piece
maybe i'm going to break open the center
and i'll have an easier time getting at
the king
all right
a train of thought
some some food for thought there
from here it's rook a to d1
and the follow-up is knight to d4 can
you guess what the best move here is for
black
f4
what is that doing it's saying uh this
is going to be too strong the capture i
don't want to see f4 breaking down e5
opening up the diagonal so
yeah computer wants to keep things
closed with f4 here but in the game it's
knight d4
knight takes that's an intolerable piece
pawn takes we now have a passer
and from here bishop to c2 there could
quickly be some pressure against a4 and
this is already now going to be a
critical moment for black
this is where black goes astray it is
around an even position 23 moves in
uh
a slight time edge for a vivid i maybe
has around a 15 minute time edge
at this stage
not 100 on that but he does have some
time advantage in this position
uh this is where black goes
wrong
uh his idea here is
to first capture and now
uh play queen to e8 this is this is the
step in the wrong direction with queen
to e8
uh the idea is to win
the a pawn
and also welcome a queen exchange black
still wants to get these queens off
as the more vulnerable king
considered better
is bishop to d7
uh
i have to show this line
it is
it is a wicked line
uh bishop to d7
check this one now
if bishop to d7 this is this is a tough
one to calculate
bishop b2 you could allow bishop takes
a4
best move now would be for white to play
rook takes d4
bishop takes queen rook takes d6
and now
the only the best move here for black
would be to play bishop d4
if you're simply moving the king
bishop d5 ouch
you got to go into a pin then the queen
falls with check
the best move for black in this position
is to play bishop d4 what's the idea
it's to open up the rook's eyes
to the d5 square it's ready to knock out
this bishop d5 move
bishop takes d4 follows
king g8
rook takes rook takes a fork in the end
and we have
a position that's basically going to be
a draw
three to two same side not much to play
for here
okay that's a very deep line a lot of
pieces flying everywhere discovered
checks
it could turn violent very quickly
after bishop to d7
anyhow
in this game it's queen to e8
bishop d2 queen takes a
white says not so fast
i don't want the queens to come off i'm
still i still have an eye on your king
this is now hit three times
queen goes back to e8 it's hit three
times it's only defended once so
white has made how many moves here rook
d1
one two three
now's the time to take the pawn right
not so fast
uh
this is what i like about these high
level games notice
you're really just extracting the the
the most
out of every move
not pulling the trigger just yet on
bishop captures d4
instead
inviting another piece into the mix rook
f e1 was played
setting up some discoveries with the
bishop
queen f7 is the follow-up
only after these two moves have been
inserted does white go ahead and capture
on d4 without question white is the side
who is benefiting
with
these two moves on board
without question this rook right here
open file much better than being on this
f-file
uh
yeah
this move is better than this one
bishop takes d4 as the follow-up
bishop takes queen takes
queen to f6
um
oh it's also not only
about
getting to an open file but if white
went ahead and captured right away on
this square there'd be queen e5 so this
rook on e1 is cutting out
this
uh queen block on e5
okay rook e1 queen f7 the capture's on
d4 queen f6
and from here white goes ahead and takes
this half dead pawn
after capturing on d4 white has restored
the material
and with this next move he's
now going up a pawn
computer likes ducking the exchange
wants to win this pawn and
try and still keep the queens on board
all right
in this one we have the queen exchange
i think we can officially say we are in
an ending
and now i believe the last important
point of this game is this move 32
and
yeah it's going to be the last pop quiz
of this
of this video
so here's the question
first of all we have some pressure on c4
how do you defend c4
i'll throw it to you as a multiple
choice
a
b
c
or d
what move would you play
feel free to pause the video
okay
the only move that allows white to still
press for a win
is
bishop to d3
all other
moves the rook defense
or even the bishop defense let's let me
just put this one on all of these moves
allow
black to play
b5
and that is a desirable break to get in
what's happening here the queen side has
been wiped out
and
without the queen side pawns
this makes life a lot easier for black
to try and hold
this to a draw keep in mind a an
important resource that black has here
and it involves this guy here being the
wrong colored bishop
so there could be some cases where it's
a bishop ending specifically and this
guy sacrifices itself for
i don't know maybe it's an f pawn or a g
pawn remaining
in the end uh yeah we have this
round-colored bishop idea
like it have
an h pawn and the bishop
versus the lone black king but it'll be
a draw
uh
bishop d3
in the in the game does not allow
b5
these guys
will remain on board and soon we're
going to see that black will be tethered
to the defense of the b-pawn and as a
result
that defending piece
its quality is greatly diminished
from here we get the kings involved
rooks enter
one rook exchange here we go not fun to
have that responsibility but
that's where we're at as black now
an active
and active versus passive rook
king e3 bishop to c6
if the bishop tried to be a bit more
aggressive here bishop e7
you could temporarily go here
have the king step up and then
make some progress once the king and
bishop are securing c4 could do
something else with the rook after the
king and bishop are watching that
okay but let's try it is bishop d7
black wants to have the bishop
guarding b7 freeing up this guy
now comes h4 white remains solid
maintains the f3 g2 structure to limit
the bishop's mobility
and this will be the
the the pawn softener
uh looking for h5 to not only
uh to not only
extend the scope of the bishop but also
the rook if the bishop is no longer on c
c6
from here king f6
bishop e4
many ways to approach it from here you
could capture push
that it pushes
have the bishops exchanged
and now we're down to an active versus
passive rook white is still up the pawn
and soon it will eventually be up
another pawn tough position now for
black
what do you do here
the rook really can't go anywhere
has to stay trained on this point
if you go to one of these two then
there's rook a7
continually putting pressure on the weak
points
what's tried is king f5 g4 came back
and there is now a
a new
seventh rank we might say
that these guys have
um
moved away from home
so this is the new seventh rank the
fifth rank
and this rook is gonna look to maybe go
here
or here and one of these will be one not
too much you could do about it as black
so discover check so what
rook f8 that's the final move
to this one move49 black resigns here
what do you do
after king e7 rook here a second pawn is
going to be one
and at this level
we don't uh play these games on the
writing is on the wall
so a very cool
game here i um
i really enjoyed covering this one there
was a lot of
stuff
out of this king's indian defense
bayonet attack a lot of
important
pawn breaks
could have turned in many directions
some nice
tricks along the way in that middle game
uh
anyhow
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you